o tedx pessoal de quem falar que exige
muito bem vindos a mais 1 bilhão é um
estrago de que um jogo que você não
tenha nada por ele muito que eu não sei
o que ele não saiu bem toda sua imagem
no início o que é isto e baldes basics
de 1.382 supostamente um jogo de tudo ou
olha vocês pediram muito para jogar no
entanto parece um jogo de aprendizagem
education and learning pé isso tentamos
parece bizarra porque o pec é um espeto
antigos sabem que o uso de 1970 então eu
acho que eu estava aqui se vocês
combinaram pokémon e zé e se vocês forem
mal aqui no canal pessoal já se
inscrevam já que nem iludam e deixam
muito leve que neste vídeo você quiser
ver mais vídeos de terror inclusive
jogos e baladas de coletadas entre
notebooks e sair da escola para ganhar é
só isso o objetivo então e construindo é
isso mas james em oito páginas um centro
livro é fácil é muito fácil já se obteve
o 1 já começa com um som muito alto o
nome ao subir não é isto nunca vão saber
que não dá pra avançar porque não dá pra
não dá afirmou afinal nada de grandes
jogos pois também cristo é o balde e nem
tomamos ficou a alguém
o laudo é que as possa fazer aqui nesta
escola possui uma escola já a terceira
escola não não funciona eu expresso meu
otimismo muito a equipe só queremos
falar com alguém consiga atravessar um
mau em regras da escola não correr não
entrar na faculdade e gays não fazer
bullying não ver não escapará à detenção
e não adversários por ed
quem vai tudo está parelho e bebeto isso
é muito puro a cair portanto 29 já que
eu não vou entrar não dá pra entrar aqui
meu a música tem muitas vezes está eu
vou muito confuso o que eu quero fazer
aqui
[Música]
a precisa ganhar dois notebooks para
atravessar aquelas portas só caí onde
estão os notebooks não faz cinema
escolher desculpa desculpa eu não posso
fugir daqui para isso começar a correr
abaixo vai ficando vermelha
olha só eu sou muito velho não quer
regras
eu não quero regra brincar não e isso ok
agora sim continua a exibir a aprovar
isso porque já não é no mouse então
vamos entrar neste primeiro e isso
parece uma sala de embarque mas quem é
esse que é correto na tarde de ontem que
o notebook é regimes precisava formato
de 1880 mesmo centavos em uma única
noite
em 2004 na en 125 995 quadro de pessoal
ainda quantos deles o ganhei isso é
muito fácil isto estão tendo reuniões ou
cai porque não vai dar um prêmio então
não sei como eu já posso comprar em que
o tesouro não disse mas eu tento usar a
moeda por ano para apanhar aí temos aqui
o tributo sobre o assunto mas de tudo
março já que chove eu não sei a música
com sua outra vez
donato steel mas matemática 5 mais uma
série na série não está em causa é de
623 né do novo fado muito não é que não
é nova
e é isto que só isso é muito alto mas eu
não sei muita coisa eu puder eu vou pôr
00 hora eo pan sobretudo com o filho
agora eu não vi um esporte meu deus mas
que só está muito alto no meu ouvido e
eu ando aqui perto do animal lei
ai cara da equipe
agora isso já consegui passar já só na
escola eu sou assim e tem uma moeda já
que o preço vai sujar meu deus
o banco também é sabido transmitir em
rápido discurso o fato de a mãe não não
posso entrar no meu deus obrigada a
ganhar é bom nem por quem eu gosto desse
jogo não é muito criativa e daí até
agora já sei que tenho que fazer para lá
agora é só apanhar os tigrinhos muito
fácil ter mais 18 25 23
eu já tenho um notebook eu consegui
apanhar isso aí eu não consigo usar isso
com calma próxima sala é muito fácil mas
aqui também mais de matemática
eu sou mestre da matemática sabe que o
cientista não falha
olha esse momento 32
ajuda a ele já que foi publicado hoje 9
8 2 3 3
outra é comigo fica no centro da capital
[Música]
foi outra vez
é agora que vai transmitir o legado olha
aí o bairro tá muito viajar é bom fugir
só tô muito mais a pena manter isso
corre pelo outro lado
ok agora já estava em frente e
concentrar me indicasse quem dá o que eu
vou entrar aqui é contra as regras mas
vou entrar aqui é mesmo mais ice isso é
pra enganar o mal e eu fui dar a volta a
isso o mel está uma sala nova eu
consegui apanhar isso e agora ficou
fácil solo eu consegui apanhar as coisas
mas não dá para fazer nada
um homem deixando de fazer de mãe é mãe
de pedro de la rosa
eu não to cuesta deixou uma serra
elétrica e turquia muito mal itaqui foge
muito confuso o que eu quero fazer é
aqui que é isso
mas o problema de matemática nós nem
5568 novo a 462 esta não dá um senão
responder não sei lá eu sou mestre em
matemática não é certo se não eu não sei
só já é um solzinho explica
você começar tudo outra vez vai buscar
bastidores eu tivesse essa matemática na
escola passada tudo que todo em moedas
o tucano já aí sim já fiz a ser usado em
1231 é só clicar já sei eu sou muito de
dor e chamou o jogo no próximo livro a
56 08 39 de sexta feira santa e acessar
através comigo não dá eu agora vou
assistir só agora vou fugir para bora
bora bora bora o máximo que conseguiu
foram três books também fundos o posto
pois por enquanto porque agora o elenco
tem que usar essa moeda não faz idéia já
sei se ocorrer isso eu gostaria que ela
baixe um homem transmite shopping suíte
com o homenzinho foi de extração de
emissões sabe que eu sou menor já venho
há muita corda
calma calma
já sylvinho controlar quando ocorre
quando dois homens
meu deus por que é que eu fui porque eu
não corri que não parece ocorrer é
mentira ela tira o sono mal comportado
não sou nenhum e agora prosseguiu eu não
sei quem é esse
através de bola só estamos novamente
fugir do baú e eu já tenho a nossa moeda
que tem outra moeda
o que nós vamos entrar aqui nessa cristo
muito a quem me conhece porque nos rio e
estóico não não acho a porta fecha a
porta
olha como isto tenho de ficar calado
fui dona doca o vovô ea filha que o
botafogo é minha pina e agora não foi
bom mas não na base do mês de treinos
paulo não vai ter água é muito podre de
juro não dá a 0 não assinar seu a anac
também eu acho que entrei no vídeo eles
concentraram ontem que o tom do que isso
bicho anda com uma pessoa calma calma
usa isto é justo o v torneio reunindo
resto ficará separado e só alma e isso
ai só tocar rápido quanto mais rápido eu
não consigo usar este então sim mais 16
125 572
isso eu não sei bora bora bora bora bora
só nessas obras o pessoal só consegui
apanhar quatro livros eram e esse é o
objetivo que não consigo usar está e
também não dá porque não tentar voltar à
mesa
anda pra que isso nem isso agora só com
o corro e sua causa eu meus 21
sou eu não conseguir andar não vai
trazer meu pai pra no
corinthians tozzo vai morrer 30 uma
vassoura
ela ficou provado
adoro a maria padre não só para agora o
que acabou de acontecer daqui muito
pessoal a alegria da corda é tão grande
a corda entre nessa sala rápida por
gente de quem fui apanhado não dos
fundiu vão apanhar
papai meu deus não dá é completamente
impossível este jogo é muito complicado
mas é isso pessoal justifica porque com
esses vídeos e eles quiserem que o jogo
mais que extingue se me quiserem ensinar
como jovem e tem muito em baixo é
futebol e comitê também as nossas dicas
não foi inscrito no canal e problemas
que se ajuda mesmo muito e sei muito
aqui também e só fiquem bem até
aproximar